why would the studio purposefully avoid
honoring one of its most popular star
wars characters with a stand-alone big
screen adventure
there's more than one reason as it turns
out here's why disney won't give
darth maul his own movie if you're not a
hardcore star wars fan you may be
surprised by the notion that maul
didn't die in the prequel trilogy there
are a lot of places you can go to find
the details of maul's story if you're
interested but suffice to say that it's
complicated
maul not only at one point builds
himself a bunch of legs out of trash
he later gets cybernetic legs that
mother talzin creates for him he goes on
to build a bunch of different crime
syndicates that serve various purposes
his backstory is rich but it's a story
that's already been told
so it may not make sense for it to be
retold in a feature film format
in order to tell a new story featuring
maul how would disney approach what he
has been through over the course of his
life
not all star wars fans have watched all
the animated series
or read all the comics and that could
impact both how understandable a mall
film would be
and interest in the film itself the best
way to approach a mall feature film
would likely be to tell the most
important parts of his life story up to
the point that a new story would take
place
depending on when in star wars history
that film was set
it could take quite a while to tell the
relevant bits of maul's history
that leaves less time for any new events
that would theoretically be the point of
the film
and that can be really complicated from
a storytelling standpoint
do fans want to sit through 30 minutes
of history that's accessible in other
formats to see an
hour or so of new content and on the
flip side
would that be accessible enough for new
viewers there's a fine line to walk
there that would likely have diminishing
returns for disney
it's easier for them to focus on
characters whose backstories are more
well-known
or create brand new characters that they
can establish on their terms
certainly a compelling story could be
told by rehashing all of maul's history
but is it worth disney's time and money
to do so
sure anti-heroes can be really
entertaining to watch there's no rule
that says that every movie
tv show comic or whatever has to have a
protagonist who is at least a little bit
good
but this is disney we're talking about
and they tend to like their leads to
not be completely on the side of
darkness maul's story while it's complex
and certainly adds depth to the
character
doesn't ever show him regretting the
things he's done and he continues to
harbor a lot of hate for a wide variety
of people across the star wars universe
throughout his life
especially the jedi it's possible to
tell a compelling backstory with this
character
absolutely but it may not have the
message that disney wishes to send
death and mayhem and fiction can be fun
to watch they just don't always endear
characters to fans
perhaps if maul had more redeeming
qualities it might be possible
but that's just not how the character
has been established and forcing that
into a movie seems antithetical to who
he is
in the history of the star wars
franchise there's never been a
villain-focused film
certainly villains are extremely
important to the universe and many of
them have captured imaginations
while some star wars villains have been
given their own books and comic series
they have never been placed at the
center of a film i was destined to
become
so much more boba fett came close but
that didn't pan out
given the good versus evil nature of the
main star wars stories
it's clear that they want you to root
for the good guys even if that's not
always how fans align
so of course as stewards of the
franchise disney seems unlikely to put
money
into featuring villains in their own
films while it's true that the prequel
trilogy focuses on anakin who becomes
darth vader
really he ceases to be the focus of the
story at the moment he does
at that point he's sidelined to being an
antagonist
if vader of all characters hasn't been
given his own film
why would maul it isn't all bad news for
maul fans though
it's been rumored that he may have
planned appearances in several upcoming
disney plus shows
including the live-action kenobi and the
animated series the bad batch
the character's appearance as a guest on
shows like these would give disney the
opportunity to use
maul without needing to delve into his
backstory to the degree they would for a
feature
film focused entirely on him the other
benefit of having maul appear on a tv
show instead of star in a feature film
is that bits and pieces of his backstory
could be explored without taking away
from the overall new content
if these rumors are true disney could be
trying to test out fan interest in the
character currently
but they wouldn't necessarily want to
over saturate their content with maul
it's also been rumored that maul could
be getting his very own disney plus
series
disney is likely determining the most
effective use of the character at this
point and if they go in the direction of
a tv show
which it seems they will it's less
likely they'll invest in a feature film
about him as well there would be no
point in double dipping that way
ultimately a tv series feels like a
better fit for the character given his
complex history and the challenges of
bringing that to a feature film
doing a show would allow disney to
explore that backstory at their leisure
while also telling a brand new story the
balance would still be very important
but it's much more manageable and longer
form storytelling
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you